en esta carrera contrarreloj para salvar
vidas el reino unido- que tiene la
presidencia pro tempore del g7 francia
de alemania buscan hoy persuadir al
presidente joe biden para que extienda
más allá del 31 de agosto es decir en
una semana la presencia de las tropas
americanas para que esta misión de
evacuación humanitaria pueda continuar y
las miles y miles de personas que están
esperando su turno para poder dejar el
país puedan hacerlo y es que la
presencia de eeuu es fundamental porque
entre otras maneja el aeropuerto de
kabul hoy en un matiz más pesimista el
ministro de defensa británico ben
wallace dijo que es poco probable que
eeuu extienda su presencia en afganistán
porque entre otras el talibán debe
aceptar esta prórroga y ya uno de sus
voceros en una entrevista con sky news
desde qatar dijo que esa fecha de
retirada es una línea roja y que si las
tropas de occidente se mantienen en
terreno afgano entonces habría
consecuencias luisa por otro lado reino
unido- como presidente del g7
pidiendo que la comunidad internacional
se una para evitar que la crisis
humanitaria y refugiados crezca qué
pasará con eso entonces
si en esta cumbre del g7 que recordemos
son los países más ricos del mundo sin
china y sin rusia el reino unido está
promoviendo que ningún país del mundo
reconozca un gobierno del talibán sin
antes exigir un marco de respeto por los
derechos humanos los derechos de las
niñas y de las mujeres para seguir
educándose y trabajar y no albergar en
su territorio organizaciones terroristas
como el estado islámico y al qaeda por
supuesto del reino unido- también está
tratando de unir a los países más ricos
para que puedan contener esa crisis de
esa crisis humanitaria que se vive en
afganistán y de refugiados pero lo más
concreto que se espera es que salgan
acciones reales para aliviar esta crisis
y ojalá salgan pronto luisa porque la
situación realmente es complicada en
afganistán gracias a por la información
desde inglaterra